la alimentación de más de 100 millones
de egipcios puede estar en riesgo a 30
kilómetros de el cairo estas granjas son
las principales abastecedoras de
productos agrícolas para el consumo
interno se ubican en la provincia de
cádiz vía en pleno delta del nilo donde
el trabajo de la tierra es vital ya que
la agricultura egipcia depende casi en
su totalidad de las cuencas de este río
pero los productores locales se sienten
desprotegidos por el estado de los
pequeños agricultores ya no pueden
comprar nada ni vender sus cosechas como
podemos pagar nuestra renta y
alimentarnos
mohamed además se queja de que no hay
algo en el canal de riego lo que retrasa
un día entero la irrigación de estos
pequeños arrozales e incrementa el costo
diario del bombeo del motor de riego al
tener que pagar alrededor de 15 dólares
de gasolina sin su trabajo la falta de
trigo debido a la guerra en ucrania
habría afectado aún más a egipto según
la organización de las naciones unidas
para la alimentación y la agricultura
fao sólo el 35 por ciento de la tierra
cultivable es trabajada campesinos
mientras que el 60 por ciento del trigo
extraído del extranjero dato que para
los productores refleja el abandono del
estado egipcio a la producción interna
algunos campesinos han abandonado su
tierra no la han vendido ni sembrado no
saben qué hacer con ella porque llevan
años perdiendo cualquiera que cultive
cebolla tomate o pimiento no hace
absolutamente ningún beneficio yo
trabajaba tres de cada diez agricultores
egipcios son analfabetas por lo que sus
alternativas económicas son escasas